tu mens le contexte d'application de la
loi
l'historique de ma proposition et enfin
son contenu le contexte la mise en place
des autorités régionales de santé des
agences régionales de santé
la mise en place de la gouvernance des
établissements hospitaliers des outils
de coopération concernent aussi bien le
secteur public que les cliniques privées
et les médecins libéraux
tout ceci ainsi que nous l'avons vu se
passe plutôt bien
en dépit des critiques de tous bords a
dressé un tel ou tel aspect du du texte
certains trouvent que la loi bras de
l'hôpital public
d'autres estiment que elle punit les
médecins libéraux mais j'ai constaté sur
le terrain que le système se mettait en
place dans d'assez bonnes conditions
mais certaines imperfections certaines
décisions du conseil constitutionnel
certaines observations du conseil d'état
certaines demandes émanant de syndicats
de médecins ou de deux médecins libéraux
ou hospitaliers m'ont convaincu de
soumettre au sénat puis demain si vous
l'estimez utile à l'assemblée nationale
quelques articles visant à supprimer à
réformer à préciser ou à compléter la
loi du 21 juillet 2009
cette proposition vise à rendre la loi
plus opérationnel et si elle peut être
mieux acceptée par l'ensemble des
praticiens et des auxiliaires qui
travaillent à son application
ce ne sera que mieux
l'historique s'étant l'automne 2010 que
j'ai pris contact avec de cabinet du
ministre de la santé de l'époque madame
bachelot pour m'assurer que les quelques
dispositions que j'avais l'intention de
proposer pour mieux organisés
les soins de premier recours pour
simplifier quelques articles trop
complexe et pour pour modifier quelques
articles au mieux intégrer enfin des
structures médico sociales dans le
domaine de compétence des agences
régionales de santé étaient
envisageables était satisfaisant après
un travail un travail en commun
approfondie et avec l'accord de madame
bachelot
j'ai pris contact avec les ordres
l'ordre des médecins l'ordre des
chirurgiens dentistes les syndicats
professionnels
les présidents la conférence des
présidents des commissions médicales
d'établissement certains directeurs
généraux des ars et j'ai déposé la
proposition numéro 65 qui comportait 14
articles
et puis deux événements sont venus me
contraindre à corriger cette proposition
d'abord certains articles ont été
heureusement repris dans la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
je me félicite que le législateur est
ainsi pris quelques gym de mes
propositions et les est introduite dans
la loi de financement
d'autre part il y a eu remaniement du
gouvernement et sur bertrand que je
salue à ce banc remplacés madame
bachelot
madame berra est venu comme secrétaire
d'état et jed entrepris de nouvelles
discussions j'ai reçu beaucoup de
propositions supplémentaires et j'ai
donc après le loup vers un nouveau tour
de discussions déposer la proposition de
loi 65 que la commission des affaires
sociales vient d'examiner et d'adopter
alors mes chers collègues
quel est le contenu de cette proposition
je ne vais pas présenté dans le détail
chacun des articles car l'excellent
rapporteur de la commission
mon ami alain milon le fera tout à
l'heure mais bien entendu comme toujours
la commission des affaires sociales a
modifié quelques articles à supprimer
d'autre à rajouter des troisièmes mais
je crois que il m'appartient de rappeler
quels étaient les objectifs de notre
opposition
j'avais trois objectifs premiers
objectifs mieux organiser les soins de
premier recours
en créant des structures efficaces
permettant un exercice en commun des
professionnels de santé relevant de
métiers différents et afin que ces
structures fonctionnent de manière
harmonieuse sur le terrain je vous
propose de supprimer quelques
dispositions difficilement applicable
est mal vécu par les médecins et par les
chirurgiens dentistes et il s'agit dans
ma proposition initiale des articles 1 à
6 le deuxième objectif c'est d'améliorer
le domaine de compétence des directeurs
généraux des ars de simplifier quelques
dispositions jugées trop floues par le
conseil d'état et d'essayer de mettre un
peu plus de liant un peu plus de
fongibilité dans l'ensemble des crédits
qui partent du sommet monsieur ministre
pour aller jusque dans les ars et afin
que ce système fonctionne il s'agit des
articles 7 à 13 dans lequel la
commission des affaires sociales a fait
son marché si j'ose dire pendant
prolonge certains et en refusant
d'autres le troisième objectif
consistait à essayer de simplifier les
mécanismes prévus pour les structures
médico-sociales à l'effet l'intégration
des établissements médico sociaux dans
le domaine de compétence drs est un
élément très important qui oblige les
directeurs généraux et leurs 7 juin à
s'occuper de manière précise de
l'ensemble de ces établissements dont on
peut dire monsieur le rapporteur général
qu'elles sont assez diverses
c'est pourquoi j'ai essayé dans les
articles 14 et 16
2 à franchir ces établissements de
procédures trop complexe pour faciliter
leur transformation et de les sécuriser
sur l'ensemble de ces articles le
rapporteur alain milon et la commission
ont fait un excellent travail et bienne
améliorer le texte simplement
j'exprimerai de regrets le premier c'est
la suppression de l'article 8 qui
donnait au directeur de la rs par des
concentrations du ministère le pouvoir
de fermer ou de suspendre l'activité de
centres de santé
ceci me permettait d'éviter que on dise
les ars vont tout faire mais chaque fois
qu'ils font quelque chose il faut qu'ils
en réfère et il faut qui est une
autorisation ministérielle ce n'est pas
de la décentralisation c'est de la
déconcentration et je crois qu'on n'est
pas allé assez loin dans le texte
le deuxième congrès que j'ai c'est la
suppression de l'article 9 le conseil
d'état a en effet observé que la
rédaction actuelle sur les fondations
médical n'était pas tout à fait claires
et que par conséquent il fallait leur
appliquer le statut les fondations
hospitalières pardon qu'il fallait leur
appliquer le statut des fondations
reconnues d'utilité publique
il m'a semblé que ce n'était pas
suffisant et par conséquent j'ai proposé
un assouplissement mais le rapporteur
dira pourquoi tout à l'heure la
commission n'a pas suivi mes
propositions
il reste doux même que cette proposition
de loi doit permettre la mise en place
cohérente harmonieuse sur le terrain de
l'ensemble des outils comme est à la
disposition de l'ensemble du monde
médical et sanitaire
la loi hpst cette proposition de loi m'a
valu un courrier extraordinaire des
propositions d'amendements relents de
partout des ordres des syndicats des
organisations diverses des défenseurs
des consommateurs etc etc
j'ai essayé de restreindre
tout ceci car l'élément important
monsieur le ministre
ça sera le rapport que le comité
d'évaluation déposera
mois de juillet qui fera le point des
grands sujets c'est à dire
l'organisation hospitalière
la coopération entre les établissements
l'organisation des réseaux de soin à
l'intérieur de l'ensemble de nos régions
mais en hors d'oeuvre si je me permets
cette proposition de loi permet de
gommer quelques aspérités et monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
j'espère que vous voudrez bien l'adopter
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant un monsieur alain milon
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues vous avez à
coeur cher jean pierre fourcade de ne
pas limiter aux travaux pourtant
absorbant du comité suivi des récentes
des établissements de santé que vous
présidez l'intérêt attentif que vous
portez comme vous tous à la mise en
oeuvre de la loi hpst
la proposition de loi dont vous êtes
l'auteur et que nous examinions
aujourd'hui tu es en effet
principalement de deux autres priorités
de la loi du 21 juillet 2009
le regain la médecine de proximité et la
place à donner au secteur médico social
dans la tente des nouvelles propositions
que vous ferez à l'issue du comité de
suivi la commission des affaires
sociales a été sensible à votre souci de
préserver l'équilibré voulu par la loi
hpst entre les différentes composantes
de notre système de santé
vous avez exprimé mon cher collègue les
regrets que vous inspire
certaines positions prises par la
commission
notre débat d'aujourd'hui permettra j'en
suis sûr de les dissiper mais permettez
moi à mon tour de vous dire que la
commission et son reporter éprouve aussi
quelques regrets des conditions d'examen
dans les délais soudainement raccourcie
d'un texte dont les dispositions les
plus importantes sont aussi celles dont
nous avons été saisis le plus
tardivement
avec ces derniers complément les
dispositions portant sur l'organisation
des soins ambulatoires et la médecine de
proximité constituent clairement le
coeur da proposition de loi et c'est
donc ce sujet que j'aborderai en premier
lieu je n'insisterai pas sur les
articles qui figurait déjà dans le
premier état du texte tendant à
supprimer des mesures peu applicable est
mal ressenti par la profession médicale
ainsi l'article 3 dha proposition noir
revenaient sur la sanctions financières
encourues par les médecins qui auraient
refusé de s'engager dans un contrat
santé solidarité ou n'en n'aurait pas
respecté les termes la commission l'a
adopté sans modification le contrat lui
même demeure
il prendra la forme d'un contrat type
conclus entre la gamme et au moins une
organisation représentative de médecins
cette solution ne présente que des
avantages et pourraient faire de ce
contrat un utile outil d'incitation
nous avons également adopté conforme
l'article 4 qui supprimait l'obligation
pour les médecins de déclarer leurs
absences programmées au conseil
départemental de l'ordre
nous avons volontiers rétabli les
contrats de bonnes pratiques et les
contraintes santé publique un peu
rapidement supprimée par l' ordonnance
d'ist de coordination du 23 février 2010
ce sont en effet des instruments qui ont
fait leurs preuves et dont la logique
est complémentaire de celle de nouveaux
contrats ayant pour objet d'améliorer la
qualité et la coordination des soins mis
en place par la loi hpst
enfin nous nous félicitons monsieur
ministre d'avoir adopté un amendement du
gouvernement devenu l'article 3 bis du
texte de la commission qui permettra
d'harmoniser les conditions de
rémunération des médecins libéraux
participantes à la permanence des soins
dans les établissements de santé publics
ou privés
tout au moins pour ce qui concerne
l'indemnisation forfaitaire de la garde
ou de l'astreinte mais j'en viens à
présente aux principales mesures
relatives à la médecine de ville qui
tout gravite autour de la question très
actuelle
des exercices pluridisciplinaire de la
médecine de proximité la cia d'abord ou
sociétés interprofessionnelles
ambulatoire que nous avons renommée cisa
société interprofessionnelle de soins
ambulatoires
bien nous en a pris nous aurions sinon
comme nous l'a fait remarquer catherine
pourre grâce aux cassia emprunté son
silo salon international de
l'agriculture
cette nouvelle forme de société a
d'abord été conçu
si nous avons bien compris pour résoudre
le problème du versement et de la
répartition des ndn amer les nouveaux
modes de rémunération expérimente est en
application web financement de la
sécurité sociale de 2008
elle offre un cadre juridique
minimaliste est néanmoins complexe
puisqu'il emprunte à la fois à la
société civile de moyens et pour les ce1
activités exercées en commun qui seront
dans un premier temps limitée à la
société civile professionnelle elle
semble traduire une certaine réticence à
l'exercice sociétale à laquelle il
faudra être attentif car il paraît
difficile que l'exercice groupe et
puissent s'accommoder d'une organisation
complètement informel
espérons en tout cas que l'affectio
societatis ne se limitera pas dans les
six à à la nécessité de disposer d'un
outil de gestion d anne hommel
quoi qu'il en soit la commission ne
pouvait guère en une semaine
allé très au-delà de simples
aménagements du texte proposé elle a
ainsi souhaité réserver aux personnes
physiques la possibilité de constituer
une 6
la participation de personne morale
étant susceptible de créer des
difficultés tant juridique que pratique
elle a supprimé le caractère optionnel
de la double nature de sm et de s&p de
la société qui n'auraient pas été source
de carte et ainsi que des dispositions
sur pf et at war ou dont la singularité
ne se justifiait pas telle la procédure
d'enregistrement à la rs
et statuts des 6 1 et leurs avenants
elle a enfin jugé utile de ne pas fermer
aux héritiers ou ayants droit d'un
associé décédé la possibilité de devenir
associés d'une sisa s'ils remplissent
des conditions requises mais nous nous
sommes aussi beaucoup interrogé sur
l'absence de relations entre ces
nouvelles sociétés et les ordres
professionnels qui nous paraît inusitée
est regrettable les ordres
professionnels n'étaient en effet même
pas mentionnée dans le texte initial où
nous a dit qu'il n'était pas possible
pour des raisons pratiques que les 6 ha
soit inscrite au tableau de tous les
ordres dont relèverait leurs associés
nous regrettons et souhaitons que soient
recherchés des moyens d'y remédier nous
avons voulu en tout cas garantir dès à
présent l'information des ordres sur
l'existence et les statuts dès 6 heures
pour l'instant la cisa apparaît encore
il faut l'admettre comme un outil
juridique sans doute perfectible et
certainement appelée à évoluer
l'expérimentation de nouveaux modes de
rémunération des personnels de santé qui
doit se poursuivre jusqu'à la fin de
2012 se doublera donc de 7 de celle
d'une nouvelle forme de société
professionnelle qui justifiera sans
doute elle aussi une évaluation
permettez moi à cet instant monsieur le
président d'ouvrir une parenthèse pour
faire part au ministre de notre souhait
d'être informés du déroulement de ces
expérimentations et des modalités
envisagées pour leur évaluation
elle devait faire l'objet d'un rapport
annuel au parlement
certes elle ment débuté qu'au début de
mais un rapport devrait devrait être
élaborée à la fin d'année dernier
et je regrette qu'il ne faisait pas été
communiqué mais je ferme cette
parenthèse l'article 2 de la proposition
de loi propose une nouvelle rédaction de
la définition des maisons de santé qui
sera la troisième depuis leur création
en 2008
cette partie de l'article n'appelle pas
de longs commentaires d'autant qu'un
nouvel amendement du gouvernement
remette en cause à la fois le texte de
la commission et celui de la proposition
de loi initiale
le joueur est en revanche insisté sur le
problème du partage des informations sur
la santé des patients que pose aussi cet
article
j'ai été j'ai pas été seul un peu
surpris par l'idée selon laquelle
l'exercice coordonnée au sein d'une
structure supposerait un élargissement
de la communication des données
personnelles et de santé des patients
la commission n'a pas non plus compris
pourquoi le partage des informations sur
la santé des patients devraient obéir à
des règles différentes selon et les
soins de ville sont assurés par des
praticiens et des auxiliaires médicaux
exerçant individuellement ou par des
professionnels regroupés dans une maison
de santé
nous n'avons en tout cas pas accepté de
considérer que le consentement au
partage des informations médicales
pouvait ce présumé et je rappellerai
dans cet hémicycle
comme j'avais fait en commission ce que
m'avait appris l'année professeur de
médecine
le secret médical appartient aux malades
j'ajoute que le droit au respect de la
vie privée est constitutionnellement
protégés
c'est dans le même esprit que nous avons
supprimé l'article 12 qui proposait avec
un peu de légèreté que l'on se passe
jusqu'à l'entrée en vigueur de la
proposition de loin que nous examinions
aujourd'hui du consentement des patients
à l'hébergement des données santé
collectés dans les établissements de
soins ce qui je viens de rappeler serait
contraire à une exigence de nature
constitutionnelle
j'ajoute qu'au moment où on espère enfin
le démarrage du dossier médical
personnel
et pour encourager
des ions un outil qui sera très utile il
nous paraît important de préserver et de
renforcer la relation de confiance entre
patient et médecin de ne pas troubler ce
colloque singulier sans lequel
d'ailleurs il n'est pas de bonne
médecine
j'en viens à présent au volet social et
médico-social la composition de loi qui
rassemble dans les trois derniers
articles du texte
des mesures simples et de bon sens notre
commission les a donc accueilli très
favorablement
l'article 14 tout d'abord permettra de
sécuriser le statut juridique des
groupement de coopération sociale et
médico-sociale léger ces sms en
supprimant une ambiguïté résultant des
modifications apportées par la loi hpst
et parlant de nans de coordination de
février 2010 sur la transposition ou non
au secteur social et médico-social de la
distinction entre gcs de moyens est gcs
établissements afin de lever toute
incertitude cet article énonce
clairement que le gcs ms n'a pas la
qualité d'établissement social ou
médico-social le gcsms n'a en effet pas
vocation à devenir un établissement
social ou médico-social titulaires d'une
autorisation
notre commission à l'époque avait émis
de profondes réserves sur la pertinence
dgcs établissement lors des amas de loi
hpst
nous approuvons donc certainement pardon
clairement et pleinement cette utile
tarification l'article case réécrit la
section 4 du budget de la caisse
nationale de solidarité pour l'autonomie
la sienne et ça voilà qui vaut
financement des actions de modernisation
des établissements et services pour
personnes âgées et personnes handicapées
et des actions de formation de
professionnalisation des personnels
intervenant auprès de ces publics
il supprime la division en deux sous
sections l'une consacre personnes âgées
l'autre aux personnes handicapées afin
de mutualiser les financements attribués
aux mêmes types d'actions il donne aussi
à la cns a la possibilité de déléguer
dans certains cas aux ars la gestion des
crédits correspondants il apporte donc
des mesures de rationalisation et des
mesures de simplification administrative
très positive et qui ont été élaborées
d'ailleurs en accord avec le cs enfin
l'article 16 propose de clarifier la
procédure applicable aux transformations
d'établissements sociaux médico-sociaux
une lecture combinée des dispositions
législatives et réglementaires laisse en
effet supposer que certains types de
transformation celle qui ne modifie pas
la catégorie bénéficiaires
d'établissement ou du service peuvent
être mises en oeuvre sans autorisation
préalable
une telle interprétation ne peut
évidemment être soutenu compte tenu des
enjeux associés à la nouvelle procédure
d'autorisation à laquelle est attachée
nombre de protection des personnes
accusent les projets de transformation
sans changement de la catégorie
bénéficia ne seront donc pas exemptes et
de la procédure d'autorisation
en revanche dans la sous- si
l'allégement des démarches
administratives ces projets seront
dispensés à l'appel de l'appel à projets
cette solution nous a paru équilibré le
temps nous est compté monsieur le
président je ne passerai pas en revue
les mesures ponctuelles et de nature
diverse que comporte la proposition de
loi nous y reviendrons dans la
discussion des articles mais je voudrais
dire un mot d'articles neufs qui
concerne les fondations hospitalières et
qui tient à coeur à notre ami jean
pierre fourcade
la loi hpst a créé cette nouvelle
catégorie de fondation en s'inspirant
des fondations universitaires pour
développer la recherche médicale et
promouvoir le transfert de crédits
privés vers la recherche publique au
sein des établissements publics de santé
un décret au conseil d'état devait fixer
les règles générales de fonctionnement
de ces fondations hospitalières mais le
projet de décret soumis au conseil
d'état n'a pas recueilli son assentiment
le conseil a relevé à juste titre que la
loi hpst ne permet pas aux fondations
hospitalières de s'affranchir de la
quasi-totalité des règles applicables
aux fondations reconnues d'utilité
publique
l'article 9 tend donc à leur permettre
d'y déroger
il prévoit par exemple que les
fondateurs disposeront
de la majorité au conseil
d'administration de la fondation et que
les directeurs généraux des ars auront
le pouvoir de contrôler les fonds
affectés aux fondations par
l'établissement puis de santé et
seulement ceux ci cette nouvelle
rédaction nous a pas paru satisfaisante
elle n'apporte en effet selon nous
aucune garantie ni en matière de
prévention des risques ou de conflits
d'intérêts ni sur le plan de contrôle de
l'utilisation des fonds publics
hospitaliers
c'est pourquoi la commission a supprimé
cet article il ne nous a pas semblé
qu'il y ait de réelles urgences
il ne nous a pas paru plus sérieux
d'approfondir la réflexion parue pardon
puis sérieux d'approfondir la réflexion
d'autant que nous pouvons parfaitement
nous en tenir aux textes actuels dans
les voyages pst et que d'autres
dispositifs juridiques peuvent être
utilisées comme les fondations de
coopération scientifique
j'ajoute d'ailleurs que pour bénéficier
des financements accordés dans le cadre
en particulier du grand emprunt le
stature qui est celui de fondation de
coopération scientifique
je mentionnerai aussi j'ai bientôt
terminé
les deux autres articles nouveau que la
commission a ajouté au texte initial de
la proposition de loi là l'article 14 à
propose la suppression des groupements
de coopération sanitaire établissements
sur lesquels nous avions exprimé d'assez
vives réserves lors de l'examen de la
loi hpst et qui ne sont toujours pas
convaincant l'autre l'article 9 bis
temps à faire avancer l'idée d'une
publication des liens d'intérêts entre
médecins et laboratoires sur le modèle
du sunshine act américain
ce texte très technique nous offrait
l'opportunité d'améliorer la loi hpst
nous ne pouvions que la saisir c'est
pourquoi monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
la commission des affaires sociales de
monde au sénat d'adopter la proposition
de loi dans le texte de la commission
complété par les amendements auquel
ifaw merci je rapporte la parole est
maintenant un monsieur xavier bertrand
ministre du travail de l'emploi et de la
santé
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre jean
pierre fourcade
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
loi hpst a profondément modernisé notre
système de santé
elle vise à mettre en place une offre de
soin graduée de qualité accessible à
tous
pour répondre à l'ensemble des besoins
de centaines aux concitoyens vous le
savez cette loi a été élaboré à l'issue
d'un long processus de concertation et
des changes des débats issus notamment
de la commission marché des échanges des
états généraux de l'organisation des
soins et les conclusions des rapports et
rf la jaune et ne nous voilons pas la
face certaines difficultés sont
néanmoins apparus dans l'application de
la loi et le gouvernement s'était engagé
à apporter les améliorations nécessaires
c'est donc d'une certaine façon à une
évaluation plus rapide et donc
nécessaire que vous avez décidé de
procéder monsieur le ministre et le
gouvernement vous soutiens totalement
dans cette démarche totalement
c'est d'ailleurs ce que permet cette
proposition de loi elle corrige
certaines dispositions qui se sont
révélés d'applications difficile elle
introduit aussi des dispositions
nouvelles qui sont apparus pour elle
même nécessaire le texte porte notamment
des mesures issues de la concertation
sur la médecine de proximité que nous
avons mené avec nora berra le 6 janvier
dernier avec les syndicats de médecins
libéraux et les étudiants et internes en
médecine générale
vous étiez d'ailleurs présents comme l'a
montré le rapport hubert remis au prix
de la république les médecins libéraux
ont besoin de mesures concrètes
notamment pour libérer du temps médical
et leur permettent de mener à bien leurs
missions premières soigner ce texte
permet ainsi de renforcer l'attractivité
de la médecine libérale de premier
recours parce que tous les français
souhaitent avoir un médecin près de chez
eux même si je n'oublie pas que dans la
médecine de proximité
il y a le médecin généraliste il y a
aussi les spécialistes
il y a aussi les paramédicaux
c'est l'objectif notamment d'un certain
nombre de points sur lesquels je
voudrais insister la création de la
société interprofessionnelle de soins
ambulatoires cette nouvelle société dans
un cadre juridique nouveau aux
professionnels de santé médicaux et
paramédicaux qui souhaitent tout
simplement travailler ensemble cette
disposition permettra de ne pas exclure
du dispositif des nouveaux modes de
rémunération les professionnels de santé
qui ont choisi d'exercer en société les
maisons de santé elles sont désormais
dotée de la personnalité juridique est
composé de professionnels médicaux
d'auxiliaires médicaux et de pharmaciens
le contrat santé solidarité
la proposition de loi retire la partie
coercitives du dispositif et ne conserve
que la part incitative du contrat les
déclarations d'absence
le texte supprime l'obligation de
déclaration des absences programmées des
médecins qui exercent en ambulatoire
quant au contrat de bonnes pratiques le
texte rétablit la base juridique des
contrats de bonnes pratiques et les
contrats de santé publique
il s'agit principalement de pouvoir
continuer à rémunérer sur une base
satisfaisante des professionnels qui ont
souscrit de tels engagements
vous le savez cette proposition de loi
est très attendu
très attendu de la part des
professionnels de santé ils souhaitent
des mesures simples pragmatiques et
efficaces pour favoriser l'exercice
médical et paramédical de proximité
les choix que nous faisons les choix que
vous nous proposez sont des choix
d'avenir
j'en profite même si ça n'est pas dans
le coeur du dispositif pour insister sur
un point sur lequel je reviendrai devant
le sénat à l'occasion des textes sur la
bioéthique en vous disant un mode
ordonnance de biologie lors de la
discussion sur le projet de loi
bioéthique un amendement a conduit à
supprimer cette ordonnance de biologie
l'assemblée nationale a voulu ainsi
donner un signal afin de soulever
plusieurs difficultés posées par cette
ordonnance notamment la nomination de ph
en biologie les ristournes sur les prix
des actes et des prélèvements par les
infirmières en cabinet libéral
je tiens à rassurer tous ceux en premier
lieu les biologistes qui s'inquiètent de
cette situation
le texte aujourd'hui reste en vigueur il
n'y a pas eu de vote sénatorial et il
n'est pas question non plus de supprimer
cette ordonnance qui permet d'organiser
le fonctionnement de la biologie de
notre pays il faut nous le savons
retravailler sur certains points
spécifiques de cette ordonnance
si le passage au sénat ce sera l'objet
des travaux des prochaines semaines en
concertation je le dis parce que je sais
monsieur le ministre que il y avait de
forts nombreuses demandes à prendre en
compte dans ce texte mais je pense qu'il
était important oui de rassurer présent
fischer je vous rejoins une fois de plus
sans vouloir vous compromettre de dire
qu'il faut rassurer pour avancer dans le
cadre d'une médecine qui est au service
de nos concitoyens c'est l'objet de ce
texte le gouvernement le soutient
totalement
merci monsieur le ministre
alors maintenant nous allons entendre
notre collègue gilbert barbier pour le
groupe rdse
seul président et ses ministres
la présidente monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues fui fruit d'un projet du
gouvernement de débats très approfondie
au parlement la loi hpst visaient à
garantir à tous nos concitoyens
l'accès à des soins de qualité en toute
sécurité sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'est ambitieux était majeure face à un
problème de la démographie médicale
notamment
c'est pourquoi si le vote de cette loi
était une étape importante
l'essentiel est surtout de réussir sa
mise en oeuvre de garantir son
application effective de rendre ses
effets tangibles pour nos concitoyens
comme tous les tous les professionnels
de santé
c'est d'ailleurs dans cette perspective
que notre collègue jean pierre fourcade
s'est vu confier tout spécialement une
mission d'évaluation de la mise en
oeuvre des mesures relatives à l'hôpital
et aux ars avec des représentants de
l'état des hôpitaux et de l'association
en attendant son rapport en juillet
prochain il propose d'ores et déjà
d'apporter à la loi hpst quelques
aménagements nous pas tant dans le
secteur hospitalier
mais pour beaucoup d articles sur ce que
l'on appelle communément les soins de
ville
un fait de mettre fin à certains
dysfonctionnements qu'il a pu constater
je savais bien entendu l'objectif de
cette proposition de loi
toutefois je regrette que sur un sujet
aussi important et complexe traitant de
volée très divers et multiples nous
n'avons eu que quelques jours pour
travailler ce texte
pourquoi une telle précipitation
la commission des affaires sociales
malgré toute la bonne volonté sa
présidente n'a pas pu saisir sur le fond
de plusieurs problèmes qui auraient
nécessité pour le moins quelques
auditions des professionnels concernés
chacun d'entre nous a pu se rendre
compte de l'émoi provoqué par certains
articles et cela est bien compréhensible
et en dépit de ces conditions difficiles
le rapporteur a effectué un travail de
qualité
s'attachant à faire la synthèse des
propositions je partage son analyse et
approuve les amendements qu'il a
présentée en commission sur deux nombres
point à l'exception de ce qui concerne
la société interprofessionnelle de soins
ambulatoires à l'article 20 de ceux
concernant les produits de santé plus
spécialement les prothèses appareillage
dentaire l'article 6 ou encore le
sunshine act à l'article 9 bis
comment d'exprimer mes réserves sur ces
points cruciaux je dois remercier notre
collègue jean pierre fourcade avoir
proposé de revenir sur deux dispositions
de la loi hpst que j'avais combattu en
son temps la pénalité attachées au
contrat de santé solidarité est la
déclaration obligatoire des absences
programmées ces mesures étaient
particulièrement vexatoires pour les
médecins
depuis plusieurs années les solutions au
problème de la démographie médicale et
de la continuité des soins font débat
surtout polémique
personnellement je l' ai toujours dit je
ne crois pas que j'ai un contexte
désaffection de la médecine libérale
les mesures coercitives soit de bonne
méthode elle serait même plutôt
dissuasive
la carrière de médecin fait certes
encore rêver des générations de jeunes
gens qui y voit non seulement une
manière de gagner leur vie mais aussi
une forme d'engagement d'altérité
d'humanisme en revanche à la différence
de leurs aînés les jeunes diplômés
rejette le schéma traditionnel du
médecin tout faire isolé dans son
cabinet corvéable jour et nuit
parmi les nouveaux inscrits à l'ordre au
1er janvier 2010 moins de 10 % exercent
en cabine est isolé deux tiers ont opté
pour une activité salariée et un quart
pour les remplacements
ce faible attrait pour l'exercice
libéral se vérifie aussi en radiologie
pourtant compte d'une discipline
considérée comme la plus lucrative
contrairement aux idées reçues ce n'est
pas le niveau insuffisant de la
rémunération qui prime le refus de
l'installation mais la charge
administrative trop lourde la solitude
de l'exercice ou encore les contraintes
des gardes en plus d'une grande
difficulté l'application les dispositifs
de la loi hpst n'apporte pas de garantie
pour une installation durable des
professionnels dans les zones sous
denses les remettent en cause la liberté
d'installation
dans un souci d'apaisement roselyne
bachelot avait mis
entre parenthèses leurs applications
aujourd'hui il est proposé de les
supprimer je m'en félicite
ceci étant je suis conscient que le
problème de l'accès et de la continuité
des soins réel dans plusieurs secteurs
du territoire non seulement milieu rural
mais aussi dans les zones suburbaines et
quartiers difficiles mais l'organisation
doit privilégier le volontariat
l'exercice collectif le rapport
d'elisabeth hubert qui a été cité remis
en novembre au président de la
république proposer un ensemble de
mesures intéressantes les connaissent et
il n'est pas lieu de les détailler
l'article 1er la proposition de loi vise
d'ailleurs à créer une nouvelle forme de
société la sisa permettant l'exercice en
commun de certaines activités par des
professionnels de santé les vents de
professions différentes
je pourrais comprendre l'intérêt
immédiat de cet article qui est de
résoudre le problème du versement de la
répartition des rémunérations perçues
dans le cadre de l'expérimentation des
nouveaux moyens de rémunération mais
avouez qu'à l'heure où nous faisons de
la simplification administrative une
priorité inventer une nouvelle structure
de surcroît aussi complexe n'a rien de
très cohérent
le rapporteur lui même disait en
commission que le statut de la spa avait
mis ses facultés d'analysé à rude
épreuve quoi qu'il en soit cet article
présente dans son écriture actuelle de
nombreuses incertitudes qui font douter
de son application et de son
interprétation
alors que l'auteur de la proposition
avait inclus les personnes morales dans
cette structure
la commission a sauté les réservé aux
seules personnes physiques
ce quelle est la justification de l'une
ou l'autre de ces positions
de même pourquoi exclure du champ de
cette nouvelle forme de société des
activités de dépistage et de prévention
il ya bien d'autres questions sur
lesquelles je reviendrai lors de
l'examen de l'article 7 6 ha
représentent à mon avis une menace grave
pour l'exercice libéral de la médecine
elle pourra conduire à des abus de
dichotomie que le texte initial avait
signalé sur le terme deux compères âge
et pourquoi pas c'est pourquoi j'en
proposerai la suppression un autre point
que me paraît loin d'être résolue
celui du coût de la traçabilité des
prothèses et appareillages notamment
dentaires nous avions longuement débattu
de cette question lors de l'adoption de
la loi hpst
bien entendu je ne remets pas en cause
le droit à l'information des patients et
la nécessité d'une plus grande
transparence
je n'ai pas non plus qu'il ya parfois
des abus et de la part de certains
chirurgiens dentistes
mais là encore n'ajoutons pas de la
complexité inutile on impose aux
professionnels de santé de communiquer
de manière dissociée le prix d'achat
chaque élément de l'appareil proposé le
prix de toutes les prestations associées
sachons reconnaître qu'un tel niveau de
détails est tout simplement impossible
et de surcroît inutile pour le patient
quel est l'intérêt de connaître le prix
de chacun des éléments d'appareillage
tels que les orthèses les sortes
prothèse qui peuvent comporter en grand
nombre de petites pièces chacun de ses
six qu'il est facile aussi de contourner
la règle
l'article 6 de la proposition de loi
initiale atténue un peu la rigueur
voulue par la loi hpst en substituant au
p d'achat le coup les matériels
cette rédaction n'a peut-être pas
totalement satisfaisante mais si nous
supprimons cet article comme l'a
souhaité la commission nous nous privons
de la possibilité de revenir sur ce
point c'est pourquoi j'ai déposé un
amendement rétablissant le texte tel que
le jean pierre fourcade n'avait présenté
sachant que la traçabilité me paraît
être l'élément déterminant pour lequel
il ne faut pas transiger
enfin l'article 9 bis sincère à
l'initiative du rap inséré à
l'initiative du rapporteur propose de
rendre public les liens d'intérêts entre
les entreprises pharmaceutiques les
membres des professions médicales
seulement d'ailleurs sur le modèle du
sunshine act américain
je suis évidemment favorable à cette
mesure en matière de santé que tout
autre l'indépendance de l'information et
de l'expertisé est un impératif s'agit
pas de stigmatiser quiconque et surtout
pas le corps médical et la gestion de la
grippe h1n1
l affaire du médiator montrent
clairement qu'un manque de transparence
jettent le discrédit sur tout le système
cela étant j'aurais préféré qu'on attend
les préconisations de la mission
d'information récemment constitué par le
sénat sur le m
à tort il y est en effet bien d'autres
aspects à traiter et la rédaction
proposée à l'article 9 bis pose des
questions comment par exemple
s'appliquera-t-il aux entreprises
étrangères
je rappelle aussi que la mission sur le
médicament que j'ai présidé à en son
temps rendu un rapport intitulé
restaurer la confiance qui
malheureusement n'a pas été entendu
monsieur le ministre
au delà des propositions qui nous sont
faites aujourd'hui il est un autre sujet
qui mérite d'être évoqué celui de la
responsabilité civile professionnelle
médicale
nous en avons débattu longuement à
plusieurs reprises la dernière fois dans
le cadre de la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale 2010 l'article 44 de
cette loi est loin d'avoir réglé le
problème des trous l'assurance les
médecins restent ainsi exposés à un
risque de ruine
tandis que les patients demeurent eux
exposés au risque d'insolvabilité des
praticiens avec d'autres collègues j'ai
déposé régulièrement un amendement
prévoyant l'intervention de l'oniam
dans tous les cas où la couverture
d'assurance médicale est épuisé ou
expiré sans que le fils ne puisse
obtenir remboursement de ces sommes j'ai
essayé de le réintroduire dans ce débat
mais les fourches caudines de l'article
40 sont passés par là monsieur le
ministre
cette affaire doit trouver sans retard
une solution car elle n'a que trop duré
et conditionnent la survie de l'exercice
libéral notamment de l'obstétrique votre
prédécesseur a confié au printemps
dernier une mission de concertation un
gilles johanet et s'est engagé devant
nous sur un calendrier remise du rapport
fin janvier 2011 les mises en oeuvre des
mesures d'application dans les trois
mois suivant
où en est-on aujourd'hui enfin un
dernier mot sur un problème soulevé par
un amendement d'autres collègues
philippe adnot et qui fait écho à un
amendement adopté par l'assemblée
nationale lors de l'examen du projet de
loi bioéthique
je veux parler des conditions d'exercice
de la profession de logique médicale
sous l'impulsion des milliers de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la santé
ces conditions était encadrée de façon
très stricte
l' ordonnance prise par le gouvernement
en janvier dernier réserve d'exercice de
la profession de biologie
east seuls médecins et pharmaciens
titulaires d'un diplôme d'études
spécialisées en biologie médicale ou
d'une qualification en biologie médicale
délivrée par les instances ordinales
regard des compétences prouvées par les
candidats certains voudraient
aujourd'hui créer une troisième voie
d'accès en permettant personnel
enseignant et hospitalier des chu non
titulaires de la formation qualifiante
d'y exercer comme biologistes médicaux
et d'assumer la responsabilité de paul
de laboratoire rejeté par le parlement
lors de l'examen de la ppl relative aux
activités immobilières des
établissements supérieurs en décembre
dernier cette initiative légitime par
ailleurs un système où les chercheurs
tendent à se coopter entre eux au
travers de critères subjectifs donnant
ainsi une image négative de notre
système hospitalo universitaires à
l'internât à l'international
l'abrogation de l'ordonnancé portant
réforme de la biologie médicale par un
amendement adopté à la sauvette sans
justification sur l'ensemble du texte
dans le cadre d'une loi la loi de
bioéthique n'ayant aucun lien avec le
sujet a provoqué l'émoi de la profession
je peux le comprendre
chassez le par la porte il revient par
la fenêtre je crois monsieur le ministre
qui n'est pas raisonnable de laisser
remettre en cause une réforme qui
s'inscrivent dans une démarche de
qualité de sécurité sanitaire et de
santé publique pour des raisons obscures
cette méthode est de surcroît méprisante
pour le travail de fond qui a été
réalisée pendant plus de deux ans par le
ministère en concertation avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de la biologie
médicale française voici une seule
ministre mes chers collègues les
quelques observations que je souhaitais
faire sur cette proposition de loi que
j'ai eu l'occasion de développer à
l'occasion de l'examen des articles vous
merci
merci collègues maintenant la parole est
un président qui fischer groupe crc
monsieur le président le service mes
chers collègues madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur il y a de cela
moins de deux ans le parlement adoptait
le projet de loi que lui avait soumis le
gouvernement hôpital patients santé
territoire censé réformer l'organisation
hospitalière sanitaire et médico-social
loin de la satisfaction partagée entre
le gouvernement et les parlementaires sa
majorité cette loi souvenez vous en a
réussi à réunir contre elle l'ensemble
des professionnels de la santé des
infirmiers au mandarin au sein des
établissements public comme du privé non
commerciales et a soulevé la colère
légitime des associations de patients
d'usagers et d'élus locaux
pour notre part nous étions convaincus
pour reprendre la formule employée alors
par mon ami françois autain qu'avec
cette loi tout convergeait vers la
privatisation de notre système de santé
depuis d'autres convictions n'a pas
changé et l'on observe chaque jour la
manière dont cette privatisation
inavoués gagnent du terrain
il faut dire cette loi part du postulat
que nous récusons selon lequel la santé
devrait être subordonnée à une logique
comptable
notre opposition à cette trêve n'exclut
naturellement pas de rechercher la
réalisation d'économies dans les
secteurs sanitaire et médico sociaux
mais à condition que ces économies ne
soient réalisés ni sur le compte des
personnels qui sont des acteurs
incontournables de la santé ni sur celui
de nos concitoyens or vos politiques
successives se sont traduits par une
réduction aveugle des moyens entraînant
une réduction importante dans l'accès
aux soins
votre obsession monsieur le ministre
de transformer l'hôpital public en des
entreprises de soins tout inspiré du
modèle privé commercial vous a conduit à
imposer la tarification à l'activité
la t2a et la convergence public-privé
ces deux mesures constituent aujourd'hui
de véritable handicap pour les hôpitaux
publics et sont lourdes de conséquences
pour nos concitoyens
je ne prendrai que deux exemples il aura
fallu attendre l'adoption de la dernière
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour qu'enfin soit précisé que
la convergence public privé ne devait
s'appliquer qu'en faveur des prix les
plus bas et non pas automatiquement en
appliquant au public
les tarifs du privé cette évolution
souhaitable constitue la démonstration
que votre priorité réside est moins dans
la réalisation de quelques économies que
dans votre volonté tout dogmatique
d'assimiler en tout point le privé au
public
je tiens d'ailleurs à cet effet a
rappelé que votre gouvernement s'est
toujours opposé à ce que l'on intègre
les tarifs des professionnels de santé
aux tarifs des établissements privés
lucratifs
cette distinction artificielle permet en
effet de faire croire que les actes
réalisés dans le privé coûte moins cher
que ceux réalisés dans dans le public
or c'est oublier que les prix pratiqués
dans le public sont si je puis dire tout
compris et intègre les honoraires des
médecins
si vous tenez tant à comparer les tarifs
du public et du privé alors vous ne
devez pas craindre la comparaison
intégral autre exemple la t2a ce mode de
financement reposant sur l'activité
réalisée au sein des établissements
n'est pas adapté à certaines activités
hospitalières
je pense particulièrement pour revenir à
un débat que nous avons eu récemment aux
soins palliatifs
selon gérard de pouvourville professeur
au département management de la santé
ce système
pousse à l'efficience mais avec un
risque dessous prise en charge des
patients et une incitation à fractionner
les séjours ce qui est naturellement
impossible dès lors qu'il s'agit de
soins palliatifs
d'ailleurs la cour des comptes le
reconnaît elle-même dans l'un de ses
rapports
le système pourrait déboucher sur une
éventuelle dégradation de la qualité des
soins prodigués ou sur une sélection des
patients pour éviter de prendre en
charge les cas les plus lourds et c'est
ce que nous observons bien souvent la
t2a présente par ailleurs chacun le sait
des effets pervers pour les comptes
sociaux
nous ne sommes pas les seuls à le penser
un rapport conjoint de l'igas et doligé
f a déjà souligné que la t2a pouvait
avoir pour effet d'entraîner une
inflation de soins chaque maladie
traitée rapportant une somme déterminée
à l'hôpital la t2a favorise par exemple
l'augmentation artificielle des durées
d'hospitalisation pour les pathologies
rémunérés à la journée encourage à tirer
le diagnostic vers l'infection la plus
lucrative et à fragmenter la prise en
charge pour multiplier les factures ou
encore à réaliser d'exact qui ne sont
pas indispensables
en somme il s'agit d'inciter les
établissements à faire du chiffre et ce
d'autant plus que depuis l'adoption de
la loi hpst
le directeur général de l'agencé
régionale de santé peut décider de
placer les établissements rencontrant
des difficultés financières sous tutelle
administrative
d'une manière générale la t2a organise
une concurrence entre les cliniques
commerciales et les hôpitaux publics une
concurrence déloyale puisque ces
derniers obligé de prendre en charge
toute l'année 7 jours sur 7 24 heures
sur 24 tous les patients qui se
présentent alors que le secteur à but
lucratif peut choisir les patients les
plus rentables
autrement dit comme le souligne
l'économiste gérard de pouvourville les
hôpitaux publics sont pénalisées par le
fait de ne pouvoir choisir leurs
patients alors on le voit bien ces deux
éléments qui sont la convergence
tarifs et la rémunération à l'activité
qui constituent l'ossature de votre
politique sanitaire joue contre
l'hôpital public c'est à dire contre les
seules structures capables d'assurer
l'égalité entre nos concitoyens en
matière d'accès aux soins
voilà je tenais à réaffirmer cela en
prélude à notre discussion
à cet égard la proposition de loi
présentée par monsieur le ministre par
notre collègue jean pierre fourcade
n'apporte aucune solution
elle entérine ce modèle économique que
nous ne pouvons que contestée par
ailleurs mes chers collègues si nous
avons cru un temps ou tout du moins
espérer que cette proposition de loi
allait porter des réponses concrètes aux
difficultés que rencontrent nos
concitoyens à accéder aux soins
aujourd'hui nous sommes déçus il s'agit
pourtant d'un enjeu capital puisque
malgré la loi hpst
malgré les règles incitatives que vous
n'avez cessé de développer l'accès aux
soins se dégrade encore
la majorité sénatoriale avait décidé
lors de l'examen de cette loi de
supprimer les quelques avancées obtenues
à l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui avec
cette proposition de loi
elle entend supprimer les quelques
mesures certes symbolique qui avait
résisté à l'examen de la loi par le
sénat et supprime les sanctions en cas
de non-respect des contrats solidaires
voilà nous y sommes 1 il s'agit avant
tout de supprimer les sanctions est
donné tous les gages au secteur libéral
tout cela mes chers collègues donne
l'impression malgré le rapport hubert
malgré le rapport valencien que vous
refusez de prendre à bras le corps
l'important dossier de la médecine
libérale
le système actuel est à bout de souffle
et ne permet pas de répondre aux besoins
de nos concitoyens
ils sont pourtant clairement définis et
se concentre sur trois questions
fondamentales la permanence des soins
la persistance et l'extension des zones
sous-médicalisées ainsi que l'explosion
des dépassements d'honoraires dont bien
entendu il ne s'agit pas d'en parler
pour nous la permanence des soins doit
continuer à être considérée comme une
mission de service public
cette exigence est une exigence de
qualité et d'égalité entre nos
concitoyens puisque seuls cette nature
est capable de rendre la permanence des
soins opposable il ne s'agit pas pour
nous de contraindre les médecins mais
d'assurer la satisfaction des besoins en
santé
c'est pourquoi nous considérons qu'elle
ne peut pas être faite culte hâtives
quant aux déserts médicaux il y à fort à
parier que malgré l'adoption probable de
cette proposition de loi et ne sort
réservé rompt pas nous n'avions pas voté
en faveur des contrats solidaires
considérant qu'ils étaient difficiles à
mettre en oeuvre mais nous avons tout de
même été surpris d'apprendre par voie de
presse que la ministre de la santé de
l'époque madame bachelot avait décidé
sol cela a été réaffirmé à l'occasion
d'un congrès des médecins généralistes
réunis à nice tu de ne pas les appliquer
je veux réaffirmer ici notre position
notre opposition à ce type de procédé le
gouvernement ne peut pas décider seul de
surseoir à l'exécution d'une mesure
adoptée par le parlement
au moins cette proposition de loi a le
mérite de clarifier les choses et permet
sans doute comme c'est comme cela que
nous le comprenons d'envoyer un signal
fort en direction des médecins qui sont
de potentiels électeurs
car à vrai dire les articles concernant
les soins de premier recours et que le
rapporteur considère est le corps de
cette proposition de loi ne nous semble
pas suffisant
le fait de permettre à une société
civile composée de médecins
d'auxiliaires médicaux de pouvoir
bénéficier de financements de la part de
l'assurance maladie n'est qu'une
incitations marginales à l'exercice
regroupé
on sait en effet que ce mode d'exercice
est aujourd'hui plébiscité et notre
rapporteur la très bien défini de plus
en plus de jeunes médecins se disent
intéressés par un exercice regroupez
vous l'avez dit monsieur me dont se
disent donc où celui ci permet
à la fois la complémentarité des
pratiques et permettent également de
rompre avec leur isolement
or ils sont aussi de plus en plus
nombreux à refuser à s'inscrire dans un
schéma où il serait d'abord et avant
tout des gestionnaires de structures ou
des entrepreneurs
cela explique sans doute pourquoi ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux à accepter
une pratique
longtemps décrié celle de l'exercice
salarié et les éléments chiffrés que
vous avez donnée monsieur alain milon et
bien par lé domaine
peut-être cette nouvelle société de
moyens de draps telle envie à des
médecins d'exercer de manière regroupée
mais la question que nous devons nous
poser est en réalité la suivante
cela suffira-t-il à réduire les déserts
médicaux
à cette question nous répondons par la
négative car elle vise en réalité à
empêcher toute remise en cause du dogme
auquel les représentants des médecins
libéraux sont très attachés celui de la
liberté d'installation pour notre part
il est temps que ce concept évolue il
est en effet pas acceptable qu'en raison
de ce principe lié un exercice libéral
les pouvoirs publics ne disposent pas à
leurs côtés des outils leur permettant
d'assurer un autre principe bien plus
important à nos yeux celui de l'accès de
tous à une médecine de proximité
les politiques incitatives que vous avez
développé depuis des années présente d
un coup deux inconvénients celui de
reposer exclusivement sur les
financements des collectivités locales
et territoriales
ce qui revient à appliquer à la médecine
de proximité
la fracture sociale dédiée aux richesses
des territoires mais aussi
d'inconvénient majeur de n'avoir aucun
effet concret nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans une situation paradoxale
il n'y a jamais eu autant de médecins et
pourtant les besoins non satisfaits
n'ont jamais été aussi grand c'est
pourquoi nous proposerons au cours de
nos débats un certain nombre
d'amendements tendant à limiter
l'installation des médecins dans les
zones sur denses et à encadrer les
conditions
leur installation je ne me fais aucune
illusion sur leur adoption
ça je vous le dis il n'y a plus lieu
d'attendre
selon les projections tout ans à croire
que le nombre de médecins de premier
recours aura tendance mécaniquement à
décroître selon les atlas régionaux de
la démographie médicale
le nom des médecins en activité devrait
en effet diminué de 10% à l'horizon 2025
si la densité médicale était de 275
généralise pour 100000 habitants 85 et 2
340 praticiens en 2005
toutes les études prévoit à l'horizon
2025 qu'elle tombe à 2 183 généralistes
pour 100000 habitants soit un taux à
peine supérieur à celui du milieu des
années 80 alors que les besoins eux ont
considérablement augmenté du fait
notamment du vieillissement de notre
population refusé d'agir aujourd'hui
c'est prendre des risques demain la
situation ne s'aggrave une nouvelle fois
enfin dernier enjeu celui de l'accès aux
soins à des tarifs opposables
cette question est primordiale dans la
mesure où l'explosion des dépassements
d'honoraires fait courir le risque d'une
médecine à double vitesse et je pense
plus particulièrement spécialistes
écartant des soins celles et ceux qui ne
disposeraient pas des ressources
financières à la hauteur de leur état de
santé à l'occasion des débats sur la loi
hpst nous avions proposé que l'accès à
des tarifs opposables soit un élément
essentiel de la détermination du schéma
régional de l'organisation sanitaire
vous vous y est opposée laissant
perdurer une situation inacceptable tout
en envoyant un très mauvais signal aux
professionnels de santé les laissant
libres de déterminer en leur âme et
conscience si les dépassements qu'ils
pratiquent sont conformes au tact et à
la mesure
aujourd'hui certains préconisent
d'autoriser la modulation vieux prix de
la consultation
en fonction de l'importance de celle-ci
nous y sommes opposés considérant
que cela reviendrait de fait à autoriser
les médecins à pratiquer des tarifs
discriminatoires ou dans le meilleur des
cas à faire naître le doute chez le
patient qui par définition a besoin de
pouvoir faire confiance aux médecins de
la même manière nous ne considérons pas
que le secteur optionnel soit de nature
à résoudre ce que l'igas estime être
dans son rapport en 2007 un recul de la
solidarité nationale contraire aux
principes fondateurs de l'assurance
maladie
ce nouveau secteur n'est pour nous
qu'une incitation direction des médecins
pratiquant les tarifs conventionnels à
imposer des dépassements d'honoraires
qui serait légalement autorisé le
pendant et en naturellement une prise en
charge par les complémentaires santé
or on sait que le transfert de la
solidarité nationale par le biais de la
sécurité sociale vers la capacité
financière des patients par le biais des
contrats complémentaires est de nature à
accroître les inégalités sociales en
santé il me reste une page mais j'ai pas
dépasser montant regarder or on sait que
le transfert de la scène alors c'est
pourquoi nous considérons qu'il est
impératif d'agir aujourd'hui et avec
courage pour garantir l'accès de toutes
et tous au tarif conventionné alors de
tout cela eh bien cette proposition de
loi ne parle pas elle se limite à une
correction à la marche de la loi hpst se
refusant d'agir sur l'essentiel
pendant que nous débattons de ce texte
les hôpitaux publics continuent à subir
des plans de rigueur sans précédent et
continuerons à les subir demain
pendant ce temps les patients continuent
à être victimes de discriminations aux
soins en fonction de leur origine de
leur régime d'assurance de leurs
ressources financières ou de leur lieu
de résidence et cela continuera demain
malgré l'adoption de cette proposition
de loi s'il fallait mes chers collègues
ne retenir qu'un qualificatif pour cette
proposition de loi ce serait sans doute
celui qui a choisi le quotidien du
médecin
de reconquête présenté dans l'article en
date du 14 février dernier comme étant
destiné à arrondir les angles entre la
majorité et les médecins vous
comprendrez aisément que dans ce
contexte et parce que l'objet de cette
ppl n'est pas la satisfaction des
besoins et attentes légitimes de nos
concitoyens que nous votions contre
cette proposition de loi
merci et discipliné mais je sais c'est
un dérapage qui vous est pas coutumier
bien mes chers collègues nous allons
maintenant entendre avec intérêts madame
roselle cros pour le groupe union
centriste
je suis heureux de l'accueillir la
tribune c'est sa première intervention
depuis guéri sénateur première
intervention à la tribune je dis bien
promu
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
effectivement nouvelle arrivée dans cet
hémicycle et membre de la commission des
affaires sociales je suis d'emblée
plongés depuis trois semaines au coeur
d'enjeux sociétaux déterminant pour
notre pays dont aujourd'hui celui de la
démographie médicale parce que ne nous
trompons pas c'est principalement de
cela dont il est question dans cette
proposition premier texte bilan de la
loi hpst du 21 juillet 2009
la présente proposition de loi ne
revient absolument pas sur son volet
semprun c'est à dire celui de la
gouvernance
c'est un texte transitoire qui nous est
soumis et disons le très diversifiées
sur ces sujets ses principaux articles
portent sur le volet ambulatoire de la
loi hpst et je me concentrerai sur ce
thème comment lutter contre la
désertification médicale et donc
préserver l'accès et la qualité des
soins
telle est la question posée question que
nous sommes déterminés à résoudre et qui
correspond à une inquiétude grandissante
de la population
la haute assemblée en a pris conscience
il ya consacré déjà une séance de
questions cribles je rappelle également
que la proposition de loi du groupe
union centriste sur la médecine du
travail entendait aussi répondre à un
problème spécifique de démographie
médicale
enfin lors de la question orale du 12
janvier dernier sur la ruralité
bruno le maire annie que l'égal accès
aux soins sur l'ensemble du territoire
était une priorité absolue dans la
perspective de cette prise de conscience
politique largement partagé la présente
proposition de loi est porteuse
d'avancées se plaçant dans une logique
d'amélioration progressive en fonction
des retours d'expérience les elle
apparaît comme encore faire perfectible
sur certains points nous ne pouvons
ainsi que souscrire à ces deux premiers
articles qui visent à faciliter
l'exercice collectif de la médecine
ambulatoire en créant la cisa société
interprofessionnelle de soins
ambulatoires
l'article 1er et répond a besoin
juridique des professionnels de santé
relevant de professions différentes et
désireux de s'associer
aujourd'hui aucun cadre ne semblent
répondre aux contraintes juridiques et
fiscales de tel groupement
c'est un frein en particulier pour les
jeunes praticiens
bien sûr la cisa n'est peut-être pas la
solution miracle mais elle mérite d'être
expérimentée quitte à ce que le
législateur en hameaux dit encore le
régime dans l'avenir l'article 2 va dans
le même sens en précisant le statut des
maisons de santé qui avait été modifié
par la loi hpst
je voudrais à cet instant salué le
sérieux et l'excellent travail technique
fournie par notre commission des
affaires sociales et en particulier par
notre rapporteur alain milon notamment
sur ces 2 articles un travail d'autant
plus fondamentale que chacun ne nous en
a bien conscience
à terme nous ne ferons reculer les
déserts médicaux qu'en développant
l'exercice regroupé et
interprofessionnel de la médecine
c'est une demande des jeunes praticiens
confronté à l'accroissement de la
complexité de leur métier en attendant
que la pratique médicale évolué en ce
sens de façon généralisée
comment influer sur la répartition de
l'offre de soins entre incitations et
sanctions le choeur des pouvoirs publics
balance et il semble désormais préférer
la citation sans vraiment porter
atteinte à l'est à l'exercice libéral la
loi hpst avait institué des mesures un
peu contraignantes pour les praticiens
qui les ont très mal vécu mesures sur
lesquelles la présente proposition de
loi entend revenir adoptant une position
centriste
je crois que sur ce thème il faut être
nuancée commençons par employé les
termes jus
l'article l 14 34 8 du code de la santé
publique prévoit une contribution
financière en cas de refus de signature
ou de manquements au contrat de santé
solidarité
cette contribution ne doit pas être
qualifié de sanctions c'est un terme qui
a choqué le milieu médical
ce qui se comprend les médecins
acceptent vous le savez d'être
sanctionnés que par leur père parlons
plutôt de pénalité en effet que nous
propose-t-on l'article 3 du texte
supprime la contributions afférentes au
contrat santé solidarité dans la loi
cette loi cette pénalité est encouru par
les praticiens à la fois en cas de refus
de contractualisation et en cas de non
respect des obligations contractuelles
nous approuvons la suppression de la
pénalité pour refus de contractualiser
les médecins sont libres et doivent le
demeurer est la base la
contractualisation n'existe que par le
volontariat
en revanche il est excessif de supprimer
également la pénalité pour non respect
des obligations contractuelles il est
bien naturel que comme dans n'importe
quel cadre contractuel le respect des
engagements soit assurée la pénalité
n'est qu'une garantie supplémentaire de
l'efficacité d'un contrat nous vous
présenterons un amendement de compromis
en ce sens amendement qui je le
mentionne ne fait que reprendre la
position qui avait été celle de notre
commission des affaires sociales lors de
l'examen de la loi hpst
l'article 4 de la proposition supprime
l'obligation faite aux médecins de
déclarer leurs absences programmées dans
le cadre de la permanence des soins
ce faisant le législateur laisse le
conseil de l'ordre
organiser librement cette permanence à
l'échelon départemental sans s'ingérer
il n'y a rien de choquant à cela bien au
contraire c'est une mesure de bon sens
il ne faut pas sous-estimer la
conscience que les médecins
de leur devoir pour la plupart d'entre
eux il est impensable de ne pas
organiser leur départ en vacances soit
pour les généralistes en installant un
remplaçant dans leur cabinet soit en
renvoyant un autre généraliste confrères
ou s'ils sont dans l'impossibilité de
faire en faisant appel au conseil de
l'ordre et ce sans que la loi ne les y
oblige
il faut rendre hommage au sens des
responsabilités des médecins qu'ils
n'abandonnent pas leur passion et ce
souci de la continuité des traitements
concernant le problème posé par
l'article 6 en matière d'information des
patients
comme vous le savez le sénat en général
et le groupe de l'union centriste en
particulier était et reste très attaché
à l'avancement à l'avancé consistant à
exiger des professionnels de santé
fournisseur de prothèses tels que les
chirurgiens dentistes qu'il délivre de
manière dissociée le prix d'achat de
chaque élément de la prairie proposée et
le prix de toutes les prestations
associées
c'est pourquoi non seulement nous
défendons le maintien de la rédaction
art actuel de l'article l 1111 3 du code
de la santé publique mais nous
soutiendrons également l'amendement de
notre collègue marie thérèse hermange
qui garantit la traçabilité des produits
de santé concernés trop de doutes
subsistent à l'heure actuelle sur la
nocivité ou la fiabilité de certains
dispositifs en contrepartie de l'abandon
de la logique de la sanction la
proposition de loi qui nous est soumise
renoue avec une logique d'incitation
financière puisque son article 5 rétabli
les contrats de bonnes pratiques et les
contrats de santé publique
ce à quoi nous sommes évidemment
favorables en dépit des faibles
résultats auxquels ils aboutissent il
conviendra sans doute de faire un effort
de communication et d'information en
direction des jeunes praticiens pour les
leur faire connaître
concernant le budget de la cns a je
voudrais faire part de mon inquiétude
relevant de la porosité croissante que
l'on observe depuis quelques temps entre
les budgets du handicap et ceux des
personnes âgées
nous connaissons les besoins
exponentiels des secteurs de la
dépendance et du grand âge nous en avons
débattu cette semaine mais dans la tente
de la réforme
rien ne justifie des tentatives
successives de ponction sur le budget du
handicap
monsieur le ministre s'il est utile de
renforcer la professionnalisation des
métiers de service est il vraiment plus
rationnelle de fusionner les lignes
budgétaires de formation des
professionnels des établissements et
services pour personnes âgées avec celle
des personnes handicapées outre le fait
qu'une fusion budgétaire a rarement pour
objectif d'augmenter les crédits
la formation de ces professionnels n'est
pas et ne doit pas être la même
car nous avons affaire à des publics
différents sinon le secteur de la
dépendance
il faut former les professionnels à
lutter contre la perte d'autonomie des
personnes âgées dans le secteur du
handicap
les professionnels doivent être formés
pour aider les personnes handicapées à
conquérir leur autonomie
ce n'est pas du tout la même chose je
rappelle que cette observation n'a rien
audacieux puisque le président de la
république a lui-même dans son récent
discours d'introduction au débat sur la
dépendance souhaité dissocier le
handicap qui concerne d'ailleurs souvent
des populations jeunes du grand âge le
handicap continuant de relever de la
solidarité nationale
le grand âge nécessitant de nouveaux
financements
en conclusion vous l'avez compris
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
sous réserve d observation juin de fer
et des amendements qui seront votés le
groupe de l'union centriste accueille
favorablement le présent texte
merci madame trop maintenant nous allons
entendre monsieur jacky le menn pour le
groupe socialiste elena we will rock you
se préparer
non
mais c'est moi qui vous le président
pardon je vais essayer monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues le président de la république
lors son déplacement à orbec dans notre
belle normandie en fin d'année dernière
et quai de la crise identitaire de la
médecine de proximité donc des médecins
libéraux qu'ils déclarent à vouloir
soigner très vite inquiet surtout des
dégâts et les taureaux risquant d'être
générés par son désamour avec cette
partie du corps médical dont la
représentation syndicale majoritaire
n'acceptait pas certaines dispositions
de la loi portant réforme de l'hôpital
et relative aux patients à la santé et
aux territoires annonça urbi et orbi un
certain nombre de mesures à prendre
toutes affaires cessantes
parmi celles ci certaines devaient
concerner la toute fraîche loi hpst
adoptée en juillet 2009 notamment les
dispositions retenues dans cette loi
pour essayer d'enrayer la
désertification médicale
moyennant quelques contraintes âprement
discutés d'ailleurs l'époque lors des
travaux du parlement
ces dispositions qui visait à
crédibiliser la volonté du législateur
dans son objectif de s'attaquer à ce
fléau que représente pour nos
concitoyens en milieu rural mais aussi
dans les nombreux quartiers et banlieues
de nos grandes métropoles la
désertification médicale aux est en
effet chi minh man introduire une
pénalisation financière à l'encontre des
médecins récalcitrants ou pour le moins
allergiques à l'idée de devoir
dorénavant réellement prendre part à la
résolution de cette lancinante question
de la désertification médicale
la confédération des syndicats médicaux
français la csmf étaient irrités vent
debout même contre cette loi hpst pour
des raisons évidemment bien différente
de celle
avancé par l'opposition parlementaire
l'époque de sa discussion devant les
deux assemblées
donc la csmf qui entend nous rapporte la
presse nettoyer la loi hpst manifesta
spectaculairement son courroux lors de
sa 16e université d'été à cannes en
septembre dernier
en omettant d'inviter ce qui était
vraiment fort inélégant madame la
ministre de la santé en exercice est ce
qui était aussi une première
si vous étiez présent l'orage grondait
il fallait faire vite si dans ce
contexte de plus ripd pré électorale à
quelques semaines des échéances
cantonales et plus important encore à un
an d'autres échéances majeures que nous
devons situer la proposition de loi qui
nous est soumise aujourd'hui cette
proposition de loi a donc été coincé
dans une niche parlementaire sénatoriale
de la majorité niche opportunément
dégagé pour caen 4 heures la messe soit
dite des propositions adaptées adopté la
loi hpst nettoyé de ses scories
litigieuse le président de la république
satisfait le corps médical libéral enfin
apaisé devant tout naturellement
retrouver au plus vite le droit chemin
qu'il n'aurait jamais dû quitter
du soutien sans faille ou plutôt sans
grogne à la politique présidentielle
dans le champ de la santé du moins pour
son versant impliquant la médecine
libérale
le président du comité de suivi de la
réforme de la gouvernance des
établissements publics de santé telle
que prévue par l'article 35 de la loi
hpst n'écoutant que son devoir nous
concoctait aussitôt une proposition de
loi visant à corriger les quelques
dispositions dérangeante contenues dans
la loi bachelot ce président notre
collègue fourcade de celui-ci a bien
pris soin de faire connaître à la presse
qu'il avait fait cette proposition et
nous l'a redit d'ailleurs à titre tout à
fait personnel et non au nom du comité
de suivi se dore je prends acte
la faire à savoir les corrections des
aspérités et dérangeant de la loi hpst
était trop urgente et ne pouvait
attendre le mois de juillet de cette
année
que l'important travail de maturation et
d'élaboration du rapport du comité de
suivi soit arrivé à son terme et
présenter dans sa cohérence d'ensemble
devant la représentation nationale
bref il fallait calmer les démangeaisons
préélectorale élyséennes et langan que
constitue cette ppl devait pouvoir
convenir
certes notre collègue fourcade dont on
connaît la sagesse a organisé sa ppl
autour de trois objectifs qui nous a
rappelé mieux organiser les soins
améliorés le domaine de compétence des
ars simplifier les mécanismes du secteur
médico social
mais il en aurait été de même au mois de
juillet si ce n'est que les propositions
sans doute aurait été plus affinée et
peut-être plus pertinente encore mes
collègues interviendront dans cette
discussion générale lui aussi tout au
long de l'examen des différentes article
constitutive de ce texte pour préciser
des positions de notre groupe face aux
diverses dispositions proposées dans ce
texte je me limiterai donc à souligner
quelques traits particulièrement
significatif de cette proposition de loi
après en avoir déploré sa rédaction
précipiter dans l'ensemble il s'agit
d'un habillage argumentative sommaire
limites sur le plan juridique
compilation proposition masquant mal
l'objectif principal recherché dont j'ai
fait état au début de mon intervention
malgré l'utilisation de quelques faux
nez sémantique d'abord comme notre à
porter le jeune autret concernant les
articles consacrés à l'organisation des
soins de premier recours qui constitue
effectivement le coeur de cette
proposition de loi ce sujet est
effectivement d'actualité
il a trait à l'exercice
pluridisciplinaire de la médecine de
proximité se faisant aurait mérité un
traitement particulièrement adaptée aux
attentes de nos concitoyens comme à
celles des professionnels concernés
quand je suis resté particulièrement
interloqué devant la rédaction initiale
de l'article nous proposant de créer
créer une cia sociétés
interprofessionnelles ambulatoire que
fort heureusement ce rare battre sans
avons rebaptisée société
interprofessionnelle de soins
ambulatoires
dans notre commission des affaires
sociales sur proposition de son
rapporteur très vigilants il s'agit nous
dit-on de créer une catégorie juridique
idoine dans le droit des sociétés pour
résoudre le problème du versement et de
la répartition des rémunérations perçues
dans le cadre de l'expérimentation des
nouvelles modalités de rémunération les
impairs prévu par la loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale en regardant cet
article il me revient à l'esprit une
boutade de notre collègue le sénateur
paul blanc qui ne manque pas d'humour
à propos d'un autre texte ayant trait à
la transposition dans notre droit
national de dispositions propres à la
législation européenne
pourquoi faire compliqué lorsqu'on peut
faire inextricable un morceau
d'anthologie
il a fallu pas moins de 12 amendements
de notre rapporteur adoptés par la
commission des affaires sociales pour
rendre cet article imprésentable cette
restauration en quelque sorte légumes en
terre d'articles promis initiale
destinée à donner un cadre juridique
permettant des professionnels de santé
d'exercer en commun faudra sans doute
écoles dans les savants séminaire de
préparation de nos futures élites
énarchique mon groupe ne votera pas cet
article 1er même reconfigurer par la
commission des affaires sociales car
nous restons persuadés qu'il est
possible d'élaborer un mécanisme plus
simple permettant la perception et la
répartition des rémunérations en cause
et pour que s'engage une véritable
réflexion de fond sur le cadre juridique
dans lequel doit s'exercer la médecine
de proximité
je relaie aussi la rédaction pour la
troisième fois consécutive depuis 2008
d'une définition des maisons de santé
créées par la loi de financement
d'assuré social pour l'année 2008 et
pense également comme notre à porter
aussi qu'il ait eu été utile puisqu'on
s'essayer à ce type d'exercice de
préciser également des statuts
concernant les pôles de santé ou les
réseaux de soins
notre commission des affaires sociales a
réécrit cet article 2 mais il faudra
bien un jour remettre l'ouvragé sur la
table si nous voulons donner une
cohérence d'ensemble des propositions
normative permettant d'assurer
une véritable organisation des soins de
premier recours dans notre pays
ce que nous cherchons en vain dans cette
proposition de loi
à ce niveau il semble opportun de
rappeler que l'article 36 de la loi hpst
a défini à la fois les soins de premier
recours et les missions du médecin
généraliste de premier recours
nous l'avions dit à l'époque que nous
avions abordé cet article pour la
discussion de cette loi hpst la portée
normative de ces définitions
légistatives n'apparaît pas clairement
depuis les spécialistes de ce type de
questions l'ont à leur tour relever
comme par exemple pirlo ibra professeur
associé à l'université paris ouest
nanterre la défense qui a fait remarquer
dans une publication professionnelle que
lesdites définition les estives avait
pour l'essentiel valeur de symbole il a
ajouté que l'enjeu majeur semble avoir
été de reconnaître l'importance des
soins primaires mais aussi le rôle
éminent joué par le médecin généraliste
dans leur dispensation faut-il y voir
l'influencé du syndicat mg france qui
depuis sa constitution sèche affirmé les
spécificités d'un messie générale il ya
tout lieu de le penser du reste les
pharmaciens d'officine soucieux de
bénéficier d'une même reconnaissance
résiste hâtive ont pu à l'époque
également obtenir l'inscription cette
fois l'article 38 de la d'histoire de la
définition de leurs missions quoi qu'il
en soit s'il est certainement
regrettable que la loi est utilisée non
pour établir strictement des droits ou
fixer des normes mais pour témoigner de
façon quelque peu incantatoire d'une
reconnaissance
cet accent mis sur les soins de premier
recours est en phase avec de nombreuses
réflexions qui insiste sur le rôle
déterminant pour garantir l'efficacité
et l'équité du système de soins dans sa
globalité
vaste question donc que les articles
nous sont soumis aujourd'hui dans cette
ppl largement reconfigurer par notre
commission des affaires sociales
n'épuise pas loin de là
cette question méritera d'autres débats
d'autres approches si nous voulons
offrir à nos concitoyens une médecine de
proximité une organisation des soins de
premier recours de grande qualité
je poursuivrai on évoqua rapidement les
fondations hospitalières autre sujet
mise à mal dans sa version hpst par le
conseil d'état cette proposition de loi
et c'est non sans mal
de revoir le statut ses fondations été
créée par la loi hpst
pour faciliter l'organisation du
financement de la recherche médicale et
permettre son développement
il existait déjà des fondation de
coopération scientifique
pourquoi un autre dispositif la question
peut se poser
de toute façon comme je lé rappeler en
commission des affaires sociales c'est
la question d'ensemble question
fondamentale du niveau global du
financement de la recherche en france
qui est posée est me semble-t-il
on ne pourra pas résoudre la question du
financement de la recherche médicale
d'une manière indépendante du
financement de l'ensemble de la
recherche
la question est bien aujourd'hui puisque
jamais de savoir quelle part de son pib
la france entend consacrer à la
recherche pour continuer à se maintenir
dans le peloton de tête des nations
développées janvier enfin l'essentiel en
quelque sorte et en quelques mots du
véritable objectif poursuivi par cette
ppl
il s'agit des trois articles e3 le 4 et
le 5 qui justifie ne soyons pas
hypocrites
l'urgence ce texte pour cent ou ses
commanditaires et plus particulièrement
au sein de cette brigade de l'article
iii concernant le contrat santé
solidarité montre anne encore rendues
opérationnelles puisque les textes
réglementaires permettant sa mise en
oeuvre n'ont volontairement pas été
publiés que dire de plus clair que ce
qu'a déclaré à la presse l'auteur ce
texte notre collègue le sénateur
fourcade je cite je souhaite supprimer
ou modifier dans la loi hpst toutes les
mesures anti médecins
donc pour ce faire s'agissant du contrat
santé solidarité dont je rappelle qu'il
a pour but de favoriser l'exercice
médical dans les zones de notre
territoire qui sont sous dotées la
proposition de loi le renvoi à la
négociation conventionnelle et supprime
les sanctions financières
donc si j'ai bien compris implicitement
jugée anti médecins prévu par la loi
hpst à l'encontre des praticiens
réfractaires soit qui refuse de
s'engager dans cette démarche soit
qu'ils ne respectent pas les termes de
leur engagement
je vous rappelle mes chers collègues
nous avons déjà eu sur ce sujet une très
longue discussion
l'examen de cette question en 2009 je
n'y reviendrai donc pas toutes les fois
en ce qui me concerne je ne vois pas
pourquoi aujourd'hui
nonobstant les déclarations et
protestations des responsables syndicaux
de la médecine libérale notamment la
csmf l'épineuse et angoissante question
de la couverture médicale des zones
sous-médicalisées sera spontanément
résolu demain grâce aux vertus de la
seule négociation conventionnelle
l'expérience du passé récent les de
l'actualité présentes témoignent du
contraire
j'espère que la sagesse de nos débats
cette fin d'après midi nous permettra de
trouver une position équilibrée dans
l'intérêt premier de nos concitoyens
malades qui souffrent de plus en plus
nombreux de l'existence 7,6
médicalisation de pans entiers de notre
territoire
je reviendrai d'ailleurs sur ce point
lors de l'examen de l'article 3 de cette
ppl
enfin s'agissant de la continuité des
soins et de l'organisation de la
permanence des soins de ville si nous
partageons l'idée du rapporteur qu'il
faut dégager des solutions
n'étant pas inutilement coercitives ou
perçu comme tel par le corps médical
libéral il ne faudrait pas pour autant
occulter le fait que cette permanence
pose problème si comme le souhaite
l'auteur de cette ppl il peut être
judicieux de resocialiser l'ordre des
médecins que de mettre en oeuvre une
disposition ressenti comme autoritaire
et inefficace par les médecins avis que
se partagent encore faut-il que l'on
nous dise d'une manière très précise
quelles seront les dispositions très
pratique qui seront mis en place pour
assurer une authentique permanence des
soins en ville à laquelle aspirent nos
concitoyens permanence qui soit aussi de
nature à désencombrer les services
d'urgences des établissements de soins
je conclurai là mon intervention
d'autres legs mon groupe interviendront
dans ce débat pour exposer votre
approche et notre position sur les
différents articles de cette proposition
de loi notamment en ce qui concerne le
secteur médico social dans le cours de
la discussion de profiteront aussi de ce
texte proposé des amendements qui nous
semble tout aussi urgent d'examiner
contenu leur objet puisque l'option a
été prise par votre majorité monsieur le
ministre
d'anticiper sur leur examen d'une partie
de la loi hpst
je termine en précisant que nous serons
bien présents dans les échanges qui ne
manqueront pas d'avoir lieu dans cette
enceinte
lorsque le rapport que doit commettre le
comité de suivi de la loi hpst aura été
déposée sur le bureau de notre assemblée
à la fin du mois de juillet je vous
remercie monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues de votre
aimable attention bien monsieur lemay
n'ayant dépassé son temps il restera
plus que 17 minutes pour les deux
orateurs du groupe socialiste qui
termineront battant madame tard et marie
thérèse hermange pour le groupe bnp
l'espace de sept minutes
non mais il faut commencer
bonjour chers le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en
réformant l'hôpital avec la loi hpst
hpst en 2009 ou portions un diagnostic
sur encore blessé afin de mieux prendre
en charge ses blessures et fractures
avec toujours cet objectif mieux
accueillir des scores souffrent eux même
blessé par la maladie cependant cette
réforme nécessaire a produit des
inquiétudes
comme si cette réforme chirurgicale
avait donné le sentiment de produire
quelques infections nosocomiales
aussi nous devons améliorer ce
diagnostic par des ennemis l'examen
complémentaire
après quelques mois de traitement c'est
tout l'objectif de la mission fourcade
et la ppl d'aujourd'hui nous donne nous
donne la possibilité de faire un bilan
d'étape en améliorant les protocoles qui
ont guéri de ceux qui ont compliqué
l'état de l'offre de soin en france tous
les essais de phase 1 ne sont donc pas
forcément à transformer en face d'eux
pourrait-on dire au moment où l'hôpital
secours trouvent donc à la croisée de
nombreux défis qui pour tous être
légitime n'en sont pas moins souvent
difficiles à concilier
le groupe ump a cherché à soutenir
l'exercice de la médecine de proximité à
mieux informer et protéger les patients
par une plus grande transparence et à
soutenir le secteur médico-social
soutenir l'exercice de la médecine de
premier recours tout d'abord c'est avec
joie que nous avons vu une occasion de
re et adopté la position initiale du
sénat lors du débat sur la loi hpst il y
a deux ans à savoir supprimer la
contribution forfaitaire annuelle pour
les médecins qui ont ce qu'ils exercent
en zones sur denses et remplacer cela
par des mesures incitatives et lever
l'obligation faite aux médecins de
déclarer leurs absences programmées
faisons confiance à ceux qui souhaitent
qu'ils prennent soin de nous jour après
jour le volontariat est suffisant
le groupe l'ump et donc attaché à la
médecine libérale et pour cela il sera
vigilant à ce que l'article 1 ne
présentent pas une menace pour
l'exercice libéral de la médecine car il
pourrait en l'état donné lieu à des
interprétations incertaine à titre
personnel je pense qu'une réflexion est
encore nécessaire pour élaborer le cadre
juridique adéquat pour l'exercice
pluriprofessionnelle de la médecine de
proximité
c'est pourquoi j'ai cosigné l'amendement
de gilbert barbier
enfin ont été rétablis les contrats de
bonnes pratiques et de santé publique
fixé par négociation conventionnelle
je reviendrai sur cette mesure à titre
personnel dans la discussion sur les
articles
car il me semble qu'il convient de ne
pas multiplier les types de contrats au
champ de compétence mêlée mais plutôt de
distinguer les objectifs poursuivis
permanence de pause soins ou bonnes
pratiques de prévention la protection
des patients ensuite un autre volet
concerne concernée par la proposition
doit et bien évidemment la protection
des patients
le partage des informations sur la santé
ne doit pas intervenir comme l'a dit le
rapporteur sans un consentement du
patient puisque le secret médical
appartient aux patients de plus alors
que le dossier médical va être relancé
il est important de ne pas semer de
confusion sur la protection des données
les scandales sur les implants et autres
prothèses
en voici un récemment sur les prothèses
mammaires plus de 3000 femmes ont déjà
porté plainte en ce qui concerne les
prothèses mammaires en ce qui concerne
les implants le scandale sur les
implants et autres prothèses
ils nous incitent aussi à insister sur
la traçabilité des prothèses et l'accès
des patients à une déclaration de
conformité explicite
en outre les crises sanitaires que nous
avons traversée nous montre d'une part
l'importance d'être paré pour agir vite
en cas d'épidémie pour éviter la
propagation et d'autre part le bénéfice
d'une réserve sanitaire
enfin l'article 9 bis fait un pas non
négligeable en avant pour favoriser la
transparence sur les liens entre
laboratoires et professions médicales en
préconisant une déclaration des
avantages directs ou indirects octroyé
par ces sociétés aux professionnels je
partage l'avis de gilbert barbier dans
la mesure où nous avons deux missions
actuellement une à l'assemblée nationale
et une au sénat je pense qu'il était
opportun d'attendre
mais comme le rapporteur a proposé un
certain nombre de mesures
je propose de les rendre effectifs et
pour cela je présenterai un amendement
en prévoyant une sanction en cas de
manquement à l'obligation de déclaration
enfin pour répondre à la fracture
public-privé et médicales et médico
social
la loi avait fait un pas de plus pour
décloisonner notre système de santé par
le renforcement des liens entre public
et privé
des mesures visent donc à sécuriser le
statut juridique des groupement de
coopération sociale ou modique au social
qui n'a pas vocation à devenir un
établissement social ou médico-social
titulaires d'une autorisation
les groupements de coopération sanitaire
d'établissements ont donc été supprimée
en commission la procédure applicable
aux transformations d'établissements
sociaux ou médico-sociaux a été
clarifiée on s'interroge cependant
toujours sur des problématiques
spécifiques la transformation
d'établissements hospitaliers en
établissements médico sociaux sera
t-elle une solution par exemple pour
demain
transformer des lits hospitaliers en
lits médicaux sociaux au lieu de
construire de nouvelles structures sont
des interrogations que nous devons avoir
à l'esprit
enfin en attendant nous nous réjouissons
d'avoir fait adopter une mesure
favorisant le développement des prises
de me des modes de prise en charge
alternative à l'hospitalisation comme la
dialyse à domicile pour toutes les
personnes qui souffrent d'insuffisance
rénale
pour toutes ces raisons monsieur le
ministre le groupe ump qui en commission
comme en séance s'est efforcé et
s'efforcera de perfectionner la loi
apporte son soutien à ce texte il
experts que demain elle deviendra une
norme vivante une norme non pas qu'ils
aient carrie et qui menace mais qui
encadrent et qui soutient avec dynamisme
la médecine et notamment la médecine de
proximité je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci chers collègues
maintenant c'est notre collègue yves
daudigny deuxième intervenant du groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur madame
la présidente de la commission mes chers
collègues pour certains d'entre nous en
tous les cas pour moi je lave ou cette
proposition de loi mort a fait découvrir
le terme deux compères âge et il me
semble justement que nous sommes réunis
ici par la grâce d'un exercice de
compérage exemplaires je voudrais bien
vous présumé innocent mon cher collègue
jean pierre fourcade
mais je serai bien le seul la poignée de
dispositions diverses jeter dans cette
proposition n'a pas fait illusion une
seconde
les deux dispositions clé de ce texte
qui sont sa seule raison d'être
saute aux yeux à la première lecture et
la presse qui est titre je cite
l'ump veut se réconcilier avec les
médecins nous prouve qu'elle sait lire
aussi il s'agit d'un article d'un
excellent quotidien national peu
susceptible d'être accusé de
malveillance vis-à-vis du gouvernement
mais souhaitait y est vous souhaitiez
vous réellement dissimuler le message
tant qu'à faire il est vrai autant
qu'ils soient le plus largement entendu
par ses destinataires
cela a été rappelé madame la ministre de
la santé s'était dès après le vote
définitif de la loi du 21 juillet mai
2009 publiquement engagé même pas
respecté la volonté du législateur et
faire changer la loi
il faut donc une loi nouvelle pour
défaire l'ancienne madame la ministre
n'avait bien sûr pas plus que vous
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre ni
certitudes ni garantie que le parlement
se pliera et se déjugera qui plus est à
si court délai vous êtes donc à la tâche
mon cher collègue et apparemment il vous
faut faire très vite le rôle n'est pas
forcément viable
tâche difficile en effet pour le
président que vous êtes également du
comité d'évaluation de la mise en oeuvre
des dispositions relatives à la
modernisation des établissements de
santé dans l'eau
hpst de justifier le dépôt prématuré de
cette proposition
puisque votre bilan est attendu pour le
21 juillet prochain et qui comporte donc
la proposition une et une seule
disposition relative aux titres 1er de
la loi
la précipitation est mauvaise
conseillère
or les articles 3 et cadre nous venons
de voir la raison d'être la plus grande
partie des autres articles de cette
proposition n'en a aucune
qui justifie ce dépôt prématurée à cet
égard je veux saluer tout
particulièrement la qualité la lucidité
et la hauteur de vue du travail d'une
autre rapporteur notamment s'agissant de
son respect affirmé aux articles 2 et 12
des droits des patients et de la vie
privée dont nous aurions pu aujourd'hui
co signé la plupart des remarques sur
les seize articles de ce texte
celui ci nous propose en effet de
supprimer purement et simplement
l'article 6 sur les dispositifs médicaux
l'article 8 sur le financement des
réseaux de santé par les ars
l'article 9 relatifs aux fondations
hospitalières
l'article 10 sur la réserve sanitaire
l'article 12 sur le consentement présumé
des patients pour l'hébergement des
données de santé
l'article 13 sur l'institut national des
invalides
la mise à nu est sévère et méritée
s'agissant de dispositions
vraisemblement rédigé à la va-vite
juridiquement contestable et dépourvus
comme le relève également de notre
rapporteur de toute évaluation nous
quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette saison si vous
souhaitez la revoir elle est disponible
en vod sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr bonne journée à tous sur
public sénat